i think your audience needs to know
something
because i i don't talk about it a lot um
every single second every
word i say and every conservative is
saying
on airways but it seems like fox talk
radio
podcasts like yours trust me you are
going to experience a lot of this
as your popularity is growing by leaps
and bounds you already got feet
i get i get my share you get your share
and i've seen it
and what people don't know is literally
millions and millions of dollars of
being spent
to record every single word we say
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everyone to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click that pesky notification bell so
that you see our videos
and joining me today is the host of
hannity on fox news
as well as the host of the sean hannity
radio show
and author of the new book live free or
die
america and the world on the brink sean
hannity finally welcome to the reuben
report
no i well thank you for having me thank
you also
because you have been an incredible
addition to
the tv show we got to get you on radio
more um
part of our we have a regular ensemble
cast you're now a part of that
um our audience loves you the feedback's
phenomenal i know how popular this
podcast is uh
you are outspoken iconoclastic uh
a free thinker uh independent
believe in freedom and liberty and free
speech and you're not part of the cancel
culture and
boycott and shut everybody down that you
disagree with and
and frankly isn't it crazy that we
conservatives are those guys that we're
the ones no
i don't want to cancel anybody boycott
anybody or get anyone fired
let people decide let people have
freedom of choice
yeah well i suppose i could just let you
go and say nice things about me but i'll
talk about that because i actually i i
got the book yesterday i read about half
of it so far but i want to start with
exactly what you just said there because
you said it to me on air a couple weeks
ago
and i thought it made a really good
point that you get boycotted
all the time you know media matters and
the rest of these guys they're
constantly coming after you
trying to take you out take out your
sponsors etc etc
but you personally never call for a
boycott for any of the guys that are
doing
far worse stuff in my opinion than
you're doing can you just talk a little
bit
about what it's like to just be in that
machine all the time just be in that
atmosphere
of boycotts and the rest of it all the
time i i think your audience needs to
know something
because i i don't talk about it a lot um
every single second every
word i say and every conservative is
saying
on airways but it seems like fox talk
radio
podcasts like yours trust me you are
going to experience a lot of this
as your popularity is growing by leaps
and bounds you already got fee
i get i get my share you get your share
i've and i've seen it
and what people don't know is literally
millions and millions of dollars of
being spent
to record every single word we say in
the hopes that we say
one word one phrase one sentence there's
one paragraph
that either that they don't like or
they'll take out of context or they'll
clip
so that they could either boycott us to
make us financially
not not viable which you know there is a
business aspect to being on the air it's
not cheap to be on the air whether it's
a podcast a radio show or tv show
because they want to silence you i i can
give you my track record
going back to the time that bill maher
now i'll be very frank
i hate bill moore i i don't like his
show i think it's gotten worse
i think he's radical extreme i disagree
with pretty much everything that's come
out of his mouth i've had him on a
as a guest a number of times uh
but i i do respect his iconoclastic
style i do respect that he'll say things
that he knows will upset people
but it was people like myself when abc
was canceling politically incorrect
that said no don't cancel this literally
standing up for him now we'll never get
credit for that
i've never had or witnessed liberals or
liberal groups now they say they're for
free speech
they're pro-choice but they're not
because every time there is
any effort to boycott any conservative
voice libertarian voice or any voice
they just don't like
it's always okay we gotta get them fired
get them canceled
boycott them so they're financially
they're not viable anymore
and then ultimately what the goal is to
get their voice off the air
every single prominent conservative this
is not
a small effort we are talking about tens
and tens of millions of dollars to do
this
and it's done it's an intimidation
tactic
and it's funny because i can tell you i
give you a long list of people that
for example i had a huge twitter feud
with jimmy kimmel
that went on for a while and and i went
adam hart
and i reminded him of all the stupid
things that he said it all started
because he was making fun of melania
trump's accent
when she was reading books to children
i'm like are we really going to pick on
women
and then i brought up all the old videos
of him
uh you know cause karma loan
you know right face yeah yeah put
putting like
cucumbers in his pants and approaching
women
from from old shows he did and then i
would always hashtag disney because i
always knew disney had no appetite for
uh controversy not to get him fired but
to send a message
you're going to be a jackass i can be a
jackass back
now when he really came under fire
recently
and apologized for that older skit as it
relates to karl men alone
uh like jimmy fallon did a year earlier
not once did i even comment on it i
stayed out of it
i had had my fight with them i'm not a
boycotter
i'm not a canceler i actually believe
that
people should have the freedom of choice
people have to choose to
listen to my radio show watch my tv show
and sign up for your podcast which is
enormously popular
it's one of the most popular podcasts
out there now and all credit to you
but you're a target too why is it the
left doesn't stand up for freedom
and liberty and free thought and
expression and and the free open
exchange
of ideas you know i'll say this too
they act like they're so outraged donald
trump
outrages him they wake up donald trump
says this or that they're outraged
it is selective feigned moral outrage
it's not
real it is phony it is it is selective
because they want to act all outright
they're not that outraged
if you're that offended by what you're
hearing on the radio or watching on tv
or choosing to
watch on a podcast if you don't like it
turn the dial
i don't want people turning the dial i
actually
i want to build my audience but i'm not
going to compromise who i am what i want
to say
or the values i stand for because
they're going to try to intimidate me
and silence my voice
i'm not going to allow i'm i'm going to
fight to my dying breath
but i'll also fight for their right to
do and say what they want to say
they've lied you know the media in
general
they've 99 of them have been lying to
the american people from the day
that donald trump and melania trump came
down that escalator at trump tower
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell